pop culture crisis hosted by Brett desic
and Mary Morgan uh guests on Friday it's
very similar to timcast IRL and its
structure super chats commentary stories
uh podcast it's live uh every uh Monday
through Monday through Friday 3: to 5:
and uh it's it's not a big political
show it's talking about like oh hey this
new movie came out this new video game
the point was to be able to have someone
some way that we could talk about pop
culture issues in this company when
we're mostly talking about news Tik Tok
banned them what was the reason of
community guidelines violations I I I
call Shenanigans I think the real issue
is controlling influence uh of their of
an adversary making sure that the work
we do can't expand timcast IRL got
banned from from Tik Tok a while ago and
then you know for no no no real reason
given they don't want us to be able to
have influence because the The Narrative
and the message that we share is good
for the United States